اذا اراد الروس الحصول على رمالنا من شاطئ
مميز ستدخل غواصه في الليل يتسلل طاقمها
يحصل على الرمال يحمله على الغواصه ويغادر
لكن اذا ارادت الصين نفس الامر سيكون
لديها 500 شخص في نزهات حول الشاطئ يلتقط
كل منهم الرمال في علب صغيره ثم يغادرون
هكذا يفرق العميل السابق لمكتب التحقيقات
الفيدراليه نيكولاس افتميادوس الاسلوب
الصيني عن الروسي وورد ذلك في كتابه
عمليات الاستخبارات الصينيه ولهذا السبب
قد تكون الصين الخصم الوحيد الاكثر فاعليه
وخطوره على الولايات المتحده ولا دليل على
ذلك اكثر من المنطاد الذي يجوب سماء
الولايات المتحده والذي تقول الصين انها
فقدت السيطره عليه يبدو صغيرا لنا في
الصور والمقاطع المصوره لكنه بحجم ثلاث
حافلات
اين هو المنطاد الان المتوقع ان يصل اليوم
للساحل الشرقي ثم ينتقل للبحر في الجنوب
الشرقي بالقربي من لكنه اختفى من موقع
التتبع
24 اليوم زاد الطينه بالله من تجسس اخر
صيني ايضا يحلق فوق امريكا اللاتينيه بحسب
البلتاجون ولم يتم تحديد موقعه بدقه حتى
الان لكن مسؤولا امريكيا ما اكد لسينان ان
المنطاد الثاني يتوجه نحو الولايات
المتحده ايضا الاجواء في واشنطن متوتره
جدا لدى الولايات المتحده تاريخا من
التجسس مع الصين وسنفصله لكم بعد قليل لكن
هذه الاجواء جعلت الخارجيه الصينيه تتهم
السياسيين ووسائل الاعلام الامريكيه
استغلال الوضع للتشويه شمعه سمعه الصين
فهي تصر على مدنيه المنطاد الذي دخل دون
قصد اجواء الولايات المتحده الامر كان
مفاج نعم لكن بالنسبه للدوله رقم واحد في
العالم كانت تعلم قبلها اطلع الرئيس جو
بايدن يوم الثلاثاء اي قبل الحادثه بيومين
على ان هناك بالون مراقبه صيني يشتبه به
يحوم فوق الولايات المتحده لكن المفارقه
هناك مدنيون هم من ابلغوا عن المنطاد
بعدما قاموا بتصويره
[موسيقى]